[Música]
hablamos de economía y cómo les fue a
los mercados en la jornada de hoy está
con nosotros en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos en
chile en el sur del continente donde el
presidente Gabriel borich propuso
cambiar el sistema de pensiones muy
controvertido allí sin duda alguna el
proyecto de ley Busca a cambiar este
actual sistema privado de administradora
de fondos de pensiones conocidas como
las afp boric planea reemplazar las aff
por un nuevo sistema de seguridad social
público privado que tendría nuevas
contribuciones de los empleadores y
también del Estado el modelo actual
Santiago de pensiones chilenos promueve
el ahorro obligatorio de los
trabajadores en una cuenta individual
administrada por estas afp y cuyos
fondos son invertidos en el mercado de
capitales ahora se propone la creación
de un sistema de jubilaciones mixto con
aportes del estado empleadores y también
trabajadores el la creación de un
organismo público que administra los
fondos y pone fin a esta gestión
exclusiva que tenían las afp Asimismo Un
aumento de la cotización que la mayoría
del 10% al 16% pero la oposición asegura
que esto terminará destruyendo el
sistema de pensiones Aunque el
financiamiento de la Reforma al sistema
de pensiones propuesta por el gobierno
depende principalmente de que se apruebe
su reforma tributaria que no cuenta con
el respaldo de la oposición y apenas
inició su discusión parlamentaria
hablemos ahora de Colombia allí la
reforma tributaria del presidente
Gustavo Petro pues ya fue aprobada por
ambas cámaras de El Congreso colombiano
así bueno el senado colombiano aprobó
esta reforma tributaria y también la
cámara de representantes hace unos
minutos hizo la aprobación de este
proyecto el gobierno de Petro Busca
recaudar el próximo año unos 4 mil
millones de dólares el proyecto se basa
en una mayor recaudación de impuestos a
personas naturales la reducción de
beneficios Fiscales a empresas en la
tributación a la pérdidas azucaradas a
la exportación de petróleo carbón y oro
cuando supere cierto techo y también a
la lucha contra la evasión uno de los
artículos más complejos de esta reforma
el del impuesto de los hidrocarburos
recibió el aval pero de él depende gran
parte de los recursos que obtendría el
gobierno con la recaudación cuando esta
iniciativa ya se convierta oficialmente
en una ley por ejemplo la zona francast
tendrá en el 20% del impuesto sobre el
valor que exporten mientras que deberán
asumir el 35%, cuando sus productos se
comercialicen en el mercado local tras
la aprobación ahora en esta ley pasa a
conciliación y luego a la sanción
presidencial bueno Jorge hablemos ahora
de esa presión internacional que tiene
Rusia porque volvió al acuerdo que le
permite a Ucrania poder exportar la
producción de granos el grupo de los
países más ricos del mundo el g7 Se
comprometió a no dejar que Rusia
infligiera hambre a los ucranianos
dijeron pero
Moscú dijo que todavía no Había decidido
si ampliar el acuerdo sobre los cereales
más allá del día 19 de noviembre el
plazo inicial que ellos habían acordado
este anuncio de que Rusia se
reincorporaba al acuerdo la ONU afirmó
que siete buques transitaban por el
corredor marítimo del mar Negro Ucrania
es uno de los principales productores de
trigo del mundo y la invasión rusa había
bloqueado 20 millones de toneladas de
grano en sus puertos hasta que se acordó
El Paso seguro escuchemos a Rebeca
griezmann negociadora comercial de
Naciones Unidas
en Estambul firmamos dos acuerdos
firmamos la iniciativa del grano del mar
Negro y firmamos un memorando de
entendimiento entre la federación rusa y
la ONU para facilitar las exportaciones
sin trabas de alimentos y fertilizantes
de la federación rusa a los mercados
mundiales
from The Reason federation
y Hablamos ahora del banco de Inglaterra
aprobó la mayor subida de los tipos de
interés en los últimos 30 años bueno
Esto siguiendo la línea de otros bancos
centrales del mundo Reino Unido situado
ahora los tipos de interés en el rango
del 3% la inflación ahí se sitúa en el
10,1% y el emisor aseguró en su
comunicado que persistirá por un tiempo
las presiones en los precios la economía
británica entró en una recesión que
durará hasta mediados del año 2024 según
representantes del banco de Inglaterra
escuchamos
si no actuamos con fuerza ahora será
peor más adelante y como muestra la
previsión que publicamos hoy nos espera
un duro camino El Fuerte aumento de los
precios de la energía provocado por la
invasión rusa de Ucrania nos ha
empobrecido como nación Es probable que
el nivel de actividad económica se
mantenga plano e incluso caiga durante
algún tiempo
y Tal parece que la incertidumbre
económica hizo que Amazon suspendiera la
contratación de empleados en Amazon
trabajan actualmente 1,5 millones de
personas y es uno de los mayores
empleadores de Estados Unidos pero ahora
se enfrenta dicen a un contexto
macroeconómico inusual en el que
necesitan equilibrar la contratación y
las inversiones tras conocerse el
anuncio de las acciones de Amazon caían
un 2% en la bolsa de Nueva York la
compañía comunicó que seguirá en
monitoreando la economía para hacer los
ajustes necesarios y para el cierre de
la cifra del día
13,700 colaboradores este es casi la
mitad de la planilla de Twitter que
supuestamente despedirá elon Moss el
multimillonario informaría los empleados
afectados el día viernes según dijeron
las fuentes a bloomberg muchas gracias
Jorge por esta actualización del mundo
económico a continuación en directo a a
continuación en directo América directo
a